to this day
if
if we start talking
it's four hours
it's it's it's it's four hours if we
exchange a sentence really yeah and it's
like it's uh it's the center of
why we've been able to sustain and
you know
why we're still
uh
together not
choking the life out of each other it's
like
the ability to work
through
issues yeah
um
i've just never i've never met another
person that i i connect with
in conversation
more
um
blissfully and productively than jada
okay
i'm not even gonna go into the big
blowout party that you had for her you
all read it here at will
that you laid down the red carpet you
had all the friends and under the and
then
you all ended up literally i think that
was the thing that actually drove there
already was a wedge but that
40th birthday party yeah was the final
moment when you said
uh
you were gonna you were no longer gonna
be in a relationship where you were
trying to make her happy yeah so how
long will you all actually separated we
never understood how long was it months
or years
uh you know
it's it's really funny we didn't
we never
actually like
officially separated
right um
what happened
was we
realized
that
it was a it was a fantasy
illusion
that we could make each other happy
and
we agreed that
she had to make herself happy
and i had to make
myself happy and then we were going to
present ourselves back to the
relationship already happy
versus demanding
that the other person fill our empty cup
hmm
you know and that should be the
pre-requisite for anybody actually
getting married absolutely it's it's
like
the
um come to me whole come to me with half
of your broken self
and expect
me to fix all the pieces the problem
is
that
when you come like that the cup actually
has a hole in the bottom right
so you pour all your good love in there
and it goes out onto the floor cause you
got two broken people you got two broken
people and that's what we're doing
you know so
there there was a
you know we just decided
that you
you have to figure out
how to be happy you know and it was it
was it was a little bit more contentious
from my side i was like you know what
you go figure it out you go figure out
if you can be happy and just prove to me
it's even possible
right not thinking about your own self
yeah and i'm a yes i'm a do me and you
do you and you say
our time apart helped us both to
discover the power of loving and freedom
we're simultaneously 100 bound together
and 100 free we agreed that we were both
imperfect people doing our best to
figure out how to be in this world
joyfully what does it mean to love in
freedom
the simple idea
is
you love in freedom with everybody
except your partner
right
your kids
are going to go off to college
and you're going to wait for them
to come back and they might not be able
to come back this christmas and you know
you you let them go your friends there's
a certain fluidity in your interactions
right it's
it's friendship
versus marital prison
oh
you